you got charged it and let it go there
you go come out yeah I did it
you know for coming and the goal is to
just odd not touch the ball last well
yeah it well the timer to 15-second 50
seconds Rawdon everyone run
no don't touch me [ __ ] get back
here Gavin's but yeah I probably with my
hiding spot [ __ ] run run wait he passed
the ball friends makes [ __ ] OOP [ __ ] hey
man hang on here oh damn it
oh I'm gonna get you don't get your
baked up gotcha [ __ ] jump blood man god
damn waiver use it hold down right click
right arm input and far commit [ __ ] OOP
but what are you gonna do Paul D hello
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] son yes
your son what
hahaha
Oh block with a microwave [ __ ] all day
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yes dodge that day yeah I thought it was
mine oh yeah [ __ ] you yeah what are you
gonna do right in the balls [ __ ] each
other ha ha ha - like the table table
oh [ __ ] up sorry kid I'm sorry I gotta
go now you get back here oh no come here
ya coming lamppost technique hey woody
uh uh oh you miss me [ __ ] nope nope
you're dead you're dead anybody
oh you suck so bad people everyone yeah
come on you can't hit anyone the big job
is ugly Piccolo's circulating your balls
the tree how are you throw like a girl
pickup commercial treatment Red Sox get
its the worst player in the world you
can sit with us you can't be hit with us
oh you can't even hit an elephant you
can't even hit your mom oh that's right
[ __ ] got Jotham oh god run run I'm
walking on sunshine well it could miss
me damn it
try Ella technique you never head says
Wow oh Ken what the [ __ ] what what hey I
got him I got him with the barrel we
contain em we can take ok you know guys
we should do a new game you guys want to
try a game let's go outside
all right so we'll play actual hot
potato
we're so like you have to say like a
theme like country's so you can only
throw it once you said something so oh
god I all bay nyet
all right I'll take the easy one United
States seems like what we did yep sis
already night uh China
oh well that's that ball it younger the
angry old man lives over there it's gone
now yeah can what the [ __ ] are you doing
even weighing in at a grand total of 15
pounds 2 ounces the new new tag team
champions of the world
the meat sheets and old records we're
here to stop dancing that was the worst
throw of all time to repeating turn that
[ __ ] off it's so annoying I'm the
announcer scream announcing can damage
alright get on the [ __ ] Billboard I'm
gonna shoot you long shot
okay look from the crowd all right I
crowd are you with me oh yeah right into
ten a dude from the crowd
yeah yeah oh good going Ken good you can
do this you know [ __ ] idiot award you
dumb [ __ ] come on man come on man oh no
does ever met them yeah yeah damn it
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
sixteen seconds huh eight seconds
don't [ __ ] move you don't fit on me
yeah Kenny's a batch all right I got a
new game all right so you're not allowed
to look up but I will throw the ball
side balances from the floor all right
yeah don't look up okay right a big ball
go oh it's coming damn it I'm do it
again
you got five we're back
oh man guys I gotta go
we should do one one giant nipple hug
yes let's do it
sorry we all touch each other so like I
said I'll talk um it's been nice Felix
I'm gay oh yeah I forgot some as
pointment on this one okay but somebody
better touch my nipples
that's it stuffed egg making I got I got
you can I got you I got your back bro
Hey Meek's oh it's you feel my back
Nichols oh yeah
Oh your back and let's just do a big
circle circle twerk um if I touch the
ball everyone touch the bar everyone
touch the ball everyone before we die
today we just have to list off whose
nipples are the best nipples that you've
ever seen oh wait everyone has to say a
secret a secret Kay Gump utility what's
your secret
um my left nut is bigger than the right
one that was my secret so uh uh uh uh
all right sometimes to help me relax at
night to sleep I touch my nipples and
dream of Sean Connery oh my god I can't
think of one make it one
okay c-54 I'm all gonna die together
guys when both explode it really gets me
off
[ __ ] you know that
ah